[Music]
i mean you have
so many things going at once right like
you have this burning desire to take
these guys down but at the same time
you're also
getting in some cases extraordinarily
close with them and finding things that
you bond with things that you respect
about them sometimes you love some of
these guys but at the same time you're
also trying to maintain your own real
love for for for for your family and
preserving the job and the oath that you
took and and and i can only imagine i
mean obviously that that that sounds
[ __ ] insanely stressful whatever but
i mean sure i'm just wondering like how
do you how do you maintain the real you
do you maintain the real you
is it compartmentalization like how does
that work well
we've hit on this uh topic a couple
times
uh i failed at that
um that's probably my my biggest
regret my biggest humiliation or
embarrassment is that
i i was in this undercover role for for
so long for such an extended period of
time like well before and and beyond the
hells angels case that
jaybird davis
the gun runner debt collector hitman
stopped becoming
what i did for a living and it started
becoming who i was but wasn't but the
but but that was necessary correct
in in order to accomplish what you
accomplished well
and and and that was at least that was
my my defense to myself and to my wife i
was like you know what
people that treat this as a gimmick
people that treat what i do as a hobby
end up dead yep right i have to be all
in i 100
because i'm gonna get killed if i'm not
right i had an argument with my wife
at one point i came home i'd been away
from the house for an extended period of
time i walk in like like jaybird davis
walks into my house right yes and she's
like you cannot be gone and come here
and treat me and our kids and talk to us
like we're street people
and i was like i'm not a light switch i
can't turn this on and off
and she's like well when you come to
this house you better install a dimmer
and dial that attitude down or don't
come back straight up and and i was like
i was super pissed off about that i was
like don't you know i'm saving the world
don't you know i'm doing all these
amazing things
and like and you're gonna give me [ __ ]
for it she was exactly right she was 100
percent justified
but you know it's it's such a la i i
guess uh
because i know how committed you are to
your family i i see your relationship
and i just in two seconds and i i i
and what you said about like chasing
that eight ball and making up for lost
time it's such a it's such a i think a
meditation on fatherhood to begin with
because i just know through your book
you know you talked about all these kids
that you would sort of come upon in the
field you would go into these houses
where people are doing meth and they're
they're [ __ ] right in front of their
kids they're selling drugs in front of
their kids there's violence right in
front of these kids and you're seeing
these these young girls that are being
tossed around you're thinking of your
own daughter and like you know i i
really believe look man for me
in this world first and foremost i'm a
dad i'm a father and i'm a husband that
is my primary that is that is my my
north star right and there's times where
i have to say you know and
but the bottom line is and i think this
is true for guys who are locked up i
think this is true for guys who are
overseas i think it's true for guys who
for whatever reason they walked away
they walked away i feel like that love
that that that bond is always there and
you always have a relationship with it
and and your north star is how healthy
that relationship is and there there's
always a way and i guess it it seems to
me like it was always present your son
gave you that rock you kept that rock
with you you know like what like i
brought i brought it you tell that story
that's who you are i mean it's like
clear and i i guess like what lessons on
fatherhood did this whole chapter in
your life teach you
it's it's it's gonna sound my answers
are gonna sound like
like kind of pathetic almost or like
like i'm seeking compassion or sympathy
and i'm not because all the decisions i
made i made [ __ ] no one made them for
me i own all of them yep but it keeps
coming back to this element of
failure or perceived failure like you
talked about like above all you're
grounded in your wife and your kids
right
like i lost that man they weren't the
most important thing to me
um
like i think inherently like i'm selfish
that's a very unflattering thing to say
about yourself
i made decisions for me about me what
was good for me what i wanted to do and
i didn't think about my wife and i
didn't think about my kids you're like
along for the ride and i and i
settled that in my head because i was
giving them i was providing them a
comfortable life they had a nice house
they had food they had clothes they went
to good schools you know my wife had had
a good car to drive they didn't have to
worry about money like i balance that by
saying like you're like i'm giving you a
comfortable life but i wasn't giving
them presents sure i wasn't giving them
i wasn't there
right i was like i was buying
my family
i was i was paying for my family by
giving them things and i thought like
like somehow that was like love or that
was a real relationship
and that i mean that's you know like
we're like we're talking to an audience
like i don't like i don't know the
people out there listen to that's a
pretty humiliating thing to say about
yourself but like we said earlier if i
don't if i if i'm not if i don't come
clean yeah like i'm counterfeit then
yeah yeah yeah i mean and also you can't
do nothing about nothing until you admit
that it's there i mean you you'll never
address a problem unless you look at it
right
well
you're like literally when you're like i
was constantly pushing the envelope and
i did everything as hard and as fast and
as long as i could and then when the
operation was done
like then the fun time came and i
partied as hard and as fast and as long
as i could and i like i pushed
i pushed the envelope every day on
everything and and my relationships and
so you know like i retired eight years
ago and like the saying like uh it's
better to um burn out than fade away i
did both i burned out and faded away i
spend so much time on my couch now i've
been reupholstered twice
[Laughter]
what is your relationship with the kids
like now it's it's really good i bet um
and my relationship with gwen is really
good i can see that um but i'll tell you
what of no credit to me
i did every single thing i could direct
that
um
there was countless times where i should
have came home and all my clothes should
have been in the front yard and the lock
should have been changed i made a
million mistakes with gwen and my kids
and i'm blessed that they've given me a
million and one second chances to fix it
beautiful um and so i'm trying to take
that one chance
yep and trying to like see if i can
finally like on the back half of my life
maybe get it right because i spent the
first half of my life getting everything
wrong and when you when you say that you
know you were like pushing the envelope
in all areas again
do you feel like that was necessary in
in order to you know especially when you
were is that the rock it is wow
wow
can you tell the story of that rock so
during the course like so my kids never
knew me as anything other than an
undercover agent they were born into it
like gwen had a chance man she knew what
i was doing before we got married so
like like she had the opportunity to say
no the kids never had an opportunity to
say no right so
like well before the hells angels case
through the hell's angels case
i'd be gone for extended period of time
you know smoking and joe can come home
and i did the bare minimum i had to to
keep my family functioning i'd mow the
grass pay the bills pat the kids on the
head have a cup of coffee with gwen
couldn't wait to get back out because i
loved being in gangster land that's why
i thrived i just loved um
like the risk of it the challenge of it
how dynamic it was how dangerous it was
um that like pushing the envelope right
all the time
so every time i'd come home and then get
ready to leave my son who was little at
time like 8 10
run out in the yard and say dad don't
leave yet like i got something for you
and he'd come and he'd bring me a rock
out of the yard
and
hundreds of times i had these rocks i i
kept i kept jackie's rocks
i kept one in my pocket at all times i
had them in the saddlebags my motorcycle
my undercover car my undercover house
these good luck charms right this kid
was giving me these good luck charms um
i started handing them out to my
partners on the task force i was like i
don't know
like what kind of blessing or charm this
kid is putting trust me on but like the
violence is swirling around us eight or
ten murders took place during that case
like all around us friends of mine
people that i was working on
i was like like please hang on to this
rock right
so the last big operation we're getting
ready to kind of wrap the case up and
we're gonna go fake this murder
right and i'm
getting ready to leave
and i tell jackie like i'll i'm almost
done
and
don't leave yet dad don't leave yet and
he brings me this rock
right and he and he and it's this rock
it's the the one he the the one that i
keep with me and he says i've been
saving this one for you it's special
it's shaped like a heart
and so like i'm a 40 year old dad and
i'm trying to comfort like this 10 year
old boy and i said all the things
that i have been neglecting with you i'm
going to fix i'm going to get done with
this and i'm going to come home and
we're going to play catch and we're
going to ride bikes and we're going to
wrestle we're going to swim and go to
the movies
right and i said it's all because of
your rocks dude these good luck charms
and i'm like they work so good i've been
giving them to all my partners
and this little boy standing on my
driveway and tears start running down
his cheeks he's standing there no shirt
no shoes and he's like
those
were not good luck charms and you
shouldn't have given them to anybody
they were just for you they were only
for you dad
and so like i'm like trying to figure
out like for years i thought he'd been
giving me good luck charms and he's like
that's for you to put in your pocket and
every time you think someone's gonna
hurt you you could put your hand in
there and touch it and that would be
like me being there to help you fight
them wow
and that was like that was the worst day
and the best day of my life the worst
day is that a ten-year-old boy had to
teach his 40-year-old father what my job
was
the best day was that my 10 year old son
taught me what my job was
and so man i put a huge amount of battle
damage on my family that's what i did to
my kids yeah all because what because i
wanted to be donny brasco part two
for what
and then you leave no one cares no one
remembers you no one remembers the cases
that you know you like you you you
retire and the next day like the people
on your task force are arguing over the
stapler on your desk who gets it that's
that's how important you are
[Music]
back